good morning John thanks for your video
this week it's been really hard
impossible maybe to think much about
policy this election season but the
really significant interest in that
video was encouraging because it means
that people do still care about policy
even if it seems like it's all about
personality and storytelling and
demonizing the other but with that said
I'm now going to go in the other
direction
I apologize and talk a bit about the
ideas and the stories that are behind
not just politics in the US right now
but I think politics all over the place
there has been a rise in nationalism and
protectionism and the story those people
are telling is often about how awful
things are about the great coming wave
of our enemies about how we have let
ourselves be corrupted and worst about
how we've consciously decided to be we I
don't even know what to call this
ideology it probably has some name that
I don't know but at its heart I feel
like there's a perspective that I cannot
abide that strength is control and that
compassion is weakness I can understand
how and why this misconception occurs if
you're strong you can make the world how
you want it to be and many want to
change how the world is maybe they need
to change how the world is they have
legitimate insecurities for themselves
and their families to go beyond that in
your rhetoric as a politician into this
country is losing rather than we need to
use the resources we have and there are
many to protect our citizens that's not
about protecting anyone to me it feels
like trying to find people's wounds
their insecurities and their biases and
then aggravating those wounds
intentionally part of the secret of this
rhetoric is that you can never call the
country strong that would be
counterproductive we can't talk about
the fact that American industrial
production is higher now than it has
ever been the job market is strong that
the American military spends more than
the next eight military's combined this
rhetoric is based on in flaming or
manufacturing fear and insecurity
because from there comes ruthlessness
comes disregard for morality comes
self-righteousness comes the framing of
people who are not like us as either
evil or corrupt whether that's Syrians
or protesters or political opponents it
can be part of our job as citizens of a
democracy to recognize when the fears
being pitched to us
are made of cardboard and styrofoam
because yes we do have huge problems to
face problems old and new that can be
influenced by good policy and good
people and good strategy but so much of
the fear we have been fed is no more
real than a Transformers movie they have
to say our country is losing because a
country that is strong digs deep not
into building walls and dehumanizing
other people it into civic service and
altruism
into openness and understanding and
peacekeeping and collaboration just as
when an individual person is confident
and self-assured the only logical course
is to try and share that great gift that
you have been given with other people is
the ultimate manifestation of strength
and because America is strong our
compassion has grown we have finally
opened up the joy of marriage to all
loving couples we have opened the doors
to immigrants and refugees we're finally
taking a look at some of our traditions
and language and recognizing the hurt
that they can cause many are open to
conversations about mass incarceration
and how it has disproportionately effect
in people of color and of course we have
a long way yet to go but to those who
see that progress as a manifestation of
weakness the people who puff themselves
up and beat their chests and yell about
strength while pouring salt into the
wounds of insecurity and fear it can
never see your rhetoric as anything
other than sad hurtful weakness weakness
that is getting in the way of our
ability to get on doing the good work
that humanity needs to do and I have no
doubt that in the fullness of time we
will move past this and we will do that
good work John I'll see you on Tuesday